of a Super Bowl commercial the pinnacle
of artistic expression when done well
they challenged the mind inspire the
heart and some only the greatest of them
all can truly evolve us and the culture
with it hey look I didn't say it evolved
us for the better
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
where we always root root root for the
home team as long as that team's mascot
a statistical analysis and the horror
began a quick shoutout to merging to you
the official first comment on the poppy
conspiracy video me that early you
either rang the subscription bell or
you're part of the Illuminati if it's
the first hey thanks for the support if
it's the second please don't make me
disappear please they have so many
series to give putting up groveling to
the Illuminati we're at that time of the
year near theorists when the national
conversation is dominated for an entire
week by a four hour marathon a grown man
running into each other to give the most
aggressive of hogs to answer the age-old
question no no I am NOT and no Monday
night football no amount of destroying
national landmarks is going to get me
ready thanks though now all of this
isn't to say that I don't like the Super
Bowl far from it actually true I might
not be the most knowledgeable person
when it comes to sports ball but I do
love gargantuan plates of chicken wings
and snarkily tweeting and halftime shows
that go hilariously arrived
so not that one on this one you knew you
left shark you knew you dance dance like
nobody's watching
nope throughout the evening away from
the pigskin there's another higher
stakes game being played that I'm more
interested in and now I'm not talking
about the kitten Bowl and talking about
the commercials almost one in four Super
Bowl viewers last year reported that
they were watching purely for the
commercials what is fascinating I mean
everything from TiVo to ad blockers to
YouTube bread seemed to indicate that
we're trying really hard to avoid
commercials but one day out of the year
we all agreed Iginla chan and company's
a 5 million dollars for just 30 seconds
in the next 10 years that number is
expected to climb to 10 million dollars
for 30 seconds at that rate someone
screaming Diet Coke at the camera for
one second would cost a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars 150 thousand for
a second but sometimes if you do it
right you create a classic like the
Apple 1984 commercial or the windi's
where's the beef at know so that I said
if you do it right because for every
memorable one there are dozens that are
forgotten faster than an American Idol
runner-up except for you click and
you'll never be invisible to me so today
I'm setting out to determine based on
the data what makes the perfect
Superbowl commercial I measured various
ads scoring systems best and worst of
the year list fluctuations and corporate
stock prices Google Trends searched data
basically everything about the
commercials from the past 10 Superbowl
to answer the ultimate question who will
win the biggest of big games the game
for Super Bowl commercial supremacy so
strap on your helmet Cirrus team and Pat
the button next to you because it's time
to kick off that's a footballing term
for starting the game now if we're going
to build a perfect Superbowl commercial
it's a good idea to start simple what
should the commercial sell the obvious
answer seems to be beer and beer
commercials dominates a list of
highest-rated ads over the past 10 years
with 23 of the top hundred ads the most
of any other product category and an
average USA Today Ad Meter score of
seven point nine one out of ten that ad
meter by the way is the most famous
reviewing mechanism for Super Bowl
commercials and a score of seven point
nine eleven means that's audiences like
though
Versalles a lot so long story short just
make a beer commercial right well those
statistics should come with an asterisk
because every one of those 23
commercials is for either Budweiser or
Bud Light and anheuser-busch which makes
both of those beers has multiple ads
running during the old big game in the
past two years sure they've had two
commercials in the top ten but four more
that didn't do nearly as well so just
being a beer isn't going to result in a
slam goal of a field down just kidding I
know enough about sports know that it's
called a homerun in fact being a beer
might be the football equivalent of
being put in the penalty box in a study
at Stanford's Graduate School of
Business around Super Bowl commercials
researchers found that when two major
competing brands advertise most of the
games of running the ad are eroded so in
other words even if you ran a great beer
ad there's a high likelihood that Bud
Light would get the credit for it anyway
instead you'll make the most money off
your commercial if nobody's selling a
product in direct competition with yours
eliminating beers cars and insurance
providers I just say I know that
football has a lot of head injuries but
really why are there so many Insurance
commercials during the Super Bowl
because I the football viewer want to
think about responsible economic
decisions while my wing stained fingers
reach for another handful of pork rinds
speaking of though snack food it's
actually the best product to advertise
during the Super Bowl for multiple
reasons one it's easy to differentiate
Doritos chips from Dan and yogurt one is
delicious and one is bacteria specific I
have never understood you yogurt you are
so strange one is delicious and one is
bacteria just can't do it
what is delicious and what god dick get
through it Matt one is delicious and one
is bacteria-infested milk and two
according to the same Stanford study if
a Super Bowl commercial can draw an
association between the consumption of
its product and watching sports well
then people are more likely to buy it in
future sports watching session okay
we're Hawking snack food but what's the
optimal time to do it according to the
data you don't want to come too early
phrasing but also don't want to risk
running too late airing a commercial
later in the game runs the risk of
missing viewers who turned the game off
because the score is in closed in 2014
for example the Seattle Seahawks
demolished the Denver Broncos 43 to 8
and by the fourth quarter the result was
a foregone conclusion
as a result at the end of the game there
were only about 46 million viewers still
left watching as such the second quarter
is ideal not only are the overall
rankings of commercials highest during
this quarter but putting your ad in the
second quarter also capitalizes on
another benefit social media traffic
this Nielsen graph shows the
distribution of tweets during last
year's Superbowl and that spike in the
middle shows that people are much more
active on Twitter during halftime airing
a commercial in the second quarter
increases the likelihood that any social
media traffic will be fresh on people's
Facebook and Twitter feeds before
everything gets buried under snarky
tweets about the halftime show thereby
getting it more views and more shares
and seriously flips face it what are you
most in the mood for a snack food
commercial early on when somebody might
actually go on a snack run during
halftime or in the fourth quarter when
you've already eaten half your body
weight nachos I mean even fat Pat has
his limit we have the topic in the
timing now all we need is the tone what
style of commercial works the best is it
better to go funny like Betty White
talking trash during a game of pickup
football funny how much your girlfriend
felt or Nia smack right in the field
like say a lost puppy who saved buy some
horses and then they become friends and
then the puppy is reunited with his
owner and why are we chopping onions in
my recording closet ok well here's the
big secret it doesn't matter if you
truly want to make a winning Super Bowl
commercial just feature an animal no
joke nothing beats the power of cute
throw in a sad puppy or a funny her to
cap and overall ad meter audience
approval scores for those commercials
leap off to an average of eight a full
one and a half points above a typical ad
spot without animals regardless of the
tone just make sure that you don't go
overboard and create something like
Mountain Dews puppy baby monkey
monstrosity of 2016 just just know it's
like an undertale amalgamate of awful
there's a reason that pile of brand
approved barf reviewed at a three point
nine out of ten of Bismil but then again
looking at the data it did create the
biggest internet response of the night
with almost fifty thousand tweets
immediately after it aired so it's the
best strategy to make the worst
commercial well no actually looking at
the stock price for PepsiCo the company
which owns mountain dew didn't do a
whole lot for biz
this the next day only getting a slight
boost of 1.17 points any marginal
benefit they got from the Super Bowl
commercial died away within the week and
actually when you come to look at the
data it's a common trend with companies
that advertise during the Super Bowl
looking at Google Trends search data
sure the data game and immediately after
searches for Doritos the commercial
winner of the last few years shows a big
spike in search but by the end of the
week they're back down to normal levels
people have moved on with their lives
and think about Doritos the same way
they've always thought about Doritos and
triangular-shaped signs of the
Illuminati and that point honestly leads
us to our ultimate answer the Illuminati
no sorry that was last video the
ultimate answer to how to create the
best Super Bowl commercial is you don't
sure you can shell out your five million
dollars grab your snack food pin down a
few cute animals show them something
funny into the second half and then
cross your fingers that the masses a are
watching B don't hate it and see no one
else's shilling for a similar product or
you just spend that five million dollars
somewhere else somewhere better
somewhere where you will actually get a
solid return on that money because
here's the thing making a Super Bowl
spot is the biggest gamble of the game
competition amongst advertisers is the
fiercest of the year not everyone
watches the commercials but most of all
the value that you get out of it is
questionable at best remember I
mentioned before that Bud Light is
usually a top contender of this thing in
fact Bud Light has been the official
beer of the NFL since 2011 and paid 1.2
billion dollars for that right but in
that time it volumes have fallen more
than 10 percent as they lose ground to
independent local craft beers sure based
on google trends brands like Doritos get
a strong bump in search every year that
they run an ad but it goes away in a few
days in fact one had a research firm
estimates that 80% of Superbowl
commercials don't boost sales another
survey by the marketing analytics agency
at Lucid showed that less than 1% of
viewers watch to influence any kind of
purchasing and looking back at history
plenty of companies that have run Super
Bowl ads have gone out of business
shortly thereafter one of the most
famous was
dot-com a company whose first commercial
was a Superbowl ad that was ranked
number one of the year and had the
highest brand recall by audiences of any
other ad and yet despite building a
bunch of brand recognition by spending
over eleven million dollars on ads that
year they only earned six hundred
nineteen thousand dollars worth of
business even the best ad of the bowl
couldn't bring in customers and they
were quickly bankrupt then there was
just four feet which went out of
business in large part thanks to their
racist ad of drugging a Kenyan runner to
give him tennis shoes or how about wicks
a company that never posted a profit but
decided to run a ten million dollar ad
anyway in the hopes of turning their
fortunes for the next two days their
stocks plummeted not only because they
didn't get new customers but because the
stock holders were like WTF are you
doing lucky for them the stock price
returned to average later in the week
even going all the way back to that
iconic Apple commercial I mentioned
before this was perhaps the commercial
that made the Superbowl ads into the
spectacle that they are today oh and
Apple tried to do it again the next year
with an ad spot showing people jumping
off a cliff like lemmings it didn't go
over so well and they wouldn't do
another ad during the big game for
another 14 years perhaps most telling of
all is assurance last year a company who
didn't run an ad during the game instead
doing it during the pregame and they
dominated social media feeding eight
times the amount of mentions of their
hashtag relative to second-place and
those are just a few select examples so
instead what do you do with that five
million dollar money pile shove it into
your mattress buy 1.7 million Crunchwrap
Supremes it's not that hungry spend it
on YouTube absolutely yes that one sure
you might think I'm playing favorites
because you know this is where I work
and all but let's compare the main value
everyone cites about the Super Bowl is
that it gets your ad in front of 100
plus million people who watch the game
okay well for five million dollars using
YouTube's ad buying tools you can pay to
have your ads show up in front of at
least a hundred million video playback
seriously that's about what the cost
would be and that's assuming five cents
per view which would be what's called
a targeted view you see by paying a bit
more I as an ad buying executive can
make sure that my ad runs in front of
certain videos in order to target
certain types of viewers it wouldn't
make much sense to run an
oil ad in front of zoella center
audiences and tuning up the car that
much but if I really wanted to I could
buy paying a bit more and for five cents
you can actually get a fair amount of
targeting in other words for five cents
of you I could force my freakish
Mountain Dew puppymonkeybaby in front of
all gamers and also everyone doing a
cringe compilation and boom suddenly I
found my perfect audience for that weird
freak show I thought was a good idea and
that clearly won't sell me anymore
Mountain Dew jumpstart but hey at least
the snarky gamers will be making fun of
it and I'll be all the trending hashtags
but not only would I have more control
over who would be watching my video I'd
be more sure that those people would be
watching my video YouTube doesn't call
them true view ads for nothing you have
to watch them in order to watch the
video that you came for and even if you
did wait two five seconds and then click
skip well that's just the same as you
tuning out the ad on TV and walking to
get more chips but at least in this case
I know that I got five solid seconds
with you and honestly the benefits keep
coming because of online data I'm able
to see the direct impact of my ad did
you click skip or did you not did you
click through to my website or did you
not so instead of spending the five
million dollars all at once and crossing
my fingers that you liked it and then it
works on that you go to my website that
you download the thing and that you buy
the app or whatever the app it is I can
instead run the ad on a small scale hone
it and recut it to make it better and
more effective and then scale it up to
that five million dollars the money is
going to be more effective meaning that
my risk as a business owner is
drastically reduced so for the same
price I'm getting just as many views
with more reliability in the eyeballs
that are watching me and also how
they're watching me this is all good
stuff and it doesn't stop there an ad
like this would have a greater chance at
virality and more staying power need an
example look no further than the one ad
that keeps kicking your ass at the
legend 27 to the legend 27 by slamming
YouTube with this ad everywhere for a
month game a board was able to drill the
epic lore of the legend 27 into enough
people's heads that it created a meme
but that has kept people talking about
it weeks after it stopped being funny
creating their own spin-offs and remix
videos it's also weeks after they
stopped running it as an ad unit that my
friends is the holy grail of advertising
resulting in not just more views but the
sort of cultural impact that was app and
where's the beef videos have had off of
the Superbowl in the
it's not a one or two day spike like
Doritos sees from advertising on the
Super Bowl it is a multi-week to multi
month to lifelong change in the way that
people speak and behave around your
product heck you could even throw some
youtubers into the mix I guarantee that
they cost a whole lot less than the 500
thousand to two million dollars
traditional celebrities charge for their
30 seconds of ads spot back I bet most
would do it for the free bag of Doritos
for an awesome selfie with
puppymonkeybaby that stuff is
social-media gold but hey that's just a
theory a film theory
and touchdown
[Applause]